I
hi guys Greg here John here breaking
[ __ ] news breakingnews Ben Affleck
will not [ __ ] direct a Batman
exclusive here reported from variety Ben
Affleck says there are certain
characters hold a special place in the
hearts of millions performing this role
demands focus passion in the very best
performance I can give is become clear
that I cannot be both jobs to the level
they require together with the studio
I've decided to find a partner in a
director who will collaborate with me on
this massive film I'm still in this and
we are making it but we are currently
looking for a director I remain
extremely committed to this project and
look forward to bringing this the Y for
fans around the world I am so bummed out
yeah that really sucks something tells
me he got a little edged out of
directing because the lid by night
because live by night loss reportedly
around 75 million dollar ah so I could
do now you did not want to take the
blame physician but I feel like live by
night probably didn't wasn't as great of
a film because he was the other [ __ ]
going on with like yeah BBS and justice
league and then I want to make a live by
night in between all this and there's
all this pressure and he's already he's
already expressing like stresses and
concerns off of having to do the Batman
how like fans are pressuring him a lot
yeah and I just feel like he kind of got
edged out I feel like maybe Warner
Brothers was like led by 975 million
dollar loss then athletes already like
guys exactly [ __ ] off for a second yeah
like it's it's not too far-fetched to
have seen this coming I was already
feeling like I want that athlete to take
his time but it seems like he's being
pressured to oh yeah why I got imagine
they want to get this movie out as
quickly as possible like Batman is the
one thing that I think everybody will
still give DC like an honest shot with
its their flagship thing everybody loves
that yeah I wouldn't be surprised at all
if if you know the ability to sleep at
night had anything to do it yeah I mean
that's just pure speculation but this
seems like a Herculean task for anybody
to take on both writing and directing
I'm glad he's still going to be Bruce
Wayne again
like I know but if I kind of wish he
he's stuck with directing instead in a
way and not start because I'm like more
curious about that but yeah if you would
have made a great Batman film I think he
would have hands now I didn't see live
my night I've seen his first three films
that he directed he's an amazing
fantastic director and this really bums
me out this was going to be monumental
but first actor to play Batman to also
direct a Batman yeah Ben Affleck with a
strong you know track record doing it
like this ah man and this only like I
and I know it makes me I mean it makes
me a little more worried about do you
seen Agatha my heart was I gonna hire
for this no I like the more stuff that
happens with DC's movies right now I
just feel like they are a problem
machine this is the last thing I was
expecting to see when I opened up you
know my Twitter feed today plums for him
is that matter i guess i mean like props
to him for it for at least you know
owning up and being like hey this is too
big of a load and we need to make a good
movie so i'll step back and now again
with DC i'm curious about what those
conversations sounded like and he can
probably view a better Batman role
because he was great in BBS we probably
would do a better job because the one
consistent issue that tends to happen
with the film's he directs was he tends
to not be the standout star yeah it has
to be like I can see like making
everyone else in the Batman would be
really cool when he's not as great as
everyone else maybe this will just will
allow him to be an even better Batman
okay so as a performer but I was really
excited to see him directed Batman yeah
and I hope that this is the true reason
because it's our Lee it's always hard to
tell with these count gosh yeah Oh guys
how bummed are you put your [ __ ]
comments down below subscribe to the
real rejects reasons a Jerry on Twitter
and Instagram social media manager of
blue mouse on the real rejects and shout
outs have been applicable I'm sorry
maybe what if Matt Damon directed it
that's not a good idea dude first
directing job with his best friend dude
Good Will Hunting reunion a Batman
perfect